I am the proud father of two beautiful
children
Elijah 15 and Octavia 12 when Elijah was
in the fourth grade he came to me came
home from school bubbling over with
excitement about what he had learned
that day about african-american history
now
I'm an african-american and cultural
studies professor and so as you can
imagine african-american culture is kind
of serious around my home so I was very
proud that my son was excited about what
he had learned that day in school so I
said well what would you learn he said I
learned about Rosa Parks
okay what did you learn about Rosa Parks
he said I learned that Rosa Parks was
this trail old black woman in the 1950s
in Montgomery Alabama and she sat down
on this bus and she had tired feet and
when the bus driver told her to give up
her seat to a white patron she refused
because she had tired feet and had been
a long day and she was tired of
oppression and she didn't give a proceed
and she marched with Martin Luther King
and she believed in non-violence and I
guess he must have looked at my face and
saw that I was a little less than
impressed by his history lesson and so
he stopped it he's like dad what's wrong
what what did I get wrong I said son you
didn't get anything wrong but I think
your teacher got a whole lot of things
wrong he said what do you mean I said
Rosa Parks was not tired she was not old
and she certainly didn't have tired feet
he said what I suggest Rosa Parks was
only 42 years old yeah you're shocked
right never heard that
Rosa Park was only 42 years old she had
only worked six hours that day and she
was the seamstress
and her feet were just fine the only
thing that she was tired of where she
was tired of inequality she was tired of
oppression and my son said well why
would my teacher you know tell me this
thing you know this is this is confusing
for me because he loved this teacher and
she was a she was a good teacher a
youngish you know twenty-something white
woman really really smart pushed him so
I liked her as well but he was confused
why would she tell me this he said he
said dad tell me more tell me more tell
me more about Rosa Parks and I said son
how do you I'll do you one better he was
like what I said I'm gonna buy her
autobiography and I'm gonna let you read
it yourself so as you can imagine
Alijah wasn't too excited about this new
lengthy homework assignment that his dad
had just given him but he took it in
stride and he came back after he had
read it and he was excited about what he
had learned he said daddy said not only
was Rosa Parks not into initially into
non-violence she said but Rosa Parks
grandfather who basically raised her and
was light enough to pass his white used
to walk around town with his gun in his
holster and people knew that if you mess
with mr. parks his children or
grandchildren he would put a cap in your
proverbial bottom right he was not
someone to mess with and he said I also
learned that Rosa Parks married a man in
Raymond who was a lot like her
grandfather right he would organize he
or she was a civil rights activist he
would organize events and sometimes the
events would be at Rosa Parks his home
and one time Rosa Parks remarked that
there were so many guns on the table
because they were prepared for somebody
to come busting into the door that they
were prepared for whatever was going to
go down the Rosa Parks said there were
so many guns on the table that offered
not to even offer him coffee or food
right this is who Rosa Parks was and in
fact Rosa Parks when she was sitting on
that bus that day waiting for those
police officers who were arrived and not
knowing what was going to happen to her
she was not thinking about Martin Luther
King who she barely knew she was not
thinking about non-violence or Gandhi
she was thinking about her grandfather a
gun-toting take no mess gun father the
grandfather that's who Rosa Parks was
thinking about and my son was mesmerized
by Rosa Parks and I was proud of him to
see this excitement but then I still had
a problem because I still had to go to a
school and address the issue with his
teacher because I didn't want her to
continue to teach the kids obviously
false history
so I'm an izing over this primarily
because I understand as an
african-american man that whenever you
talk to whites about racism or anything
that's racially sensitive there's
usually going to be a challenge this is
what sociologist white sociologist Robyn
D'Angelo calls white fragility she
argues that in fact because whites have
so little experience being challenged
about their white privilege that
whenever even the most my new challenge
is brought before them they usually cry
get angry or run and I have experienced
them all and so when I was contemplating
confronting his teacher I wasn't wasn't
happy about it but I was like this is a
necessary evil of being a black parent
trying to raise self actualize black
children so I called Elijah to me I said
Elijah I'm gonna tell your teacher you
know I'm gonna set up an appointment
your teacher and try and correct this
and maybe your principal what do you
think and Elijah said that I have a
better idea and I said really what's
your idea he said we have a public
speaking assignment and why don't I use
that public speaking assignment to talk
about debunking the myths of Rosa Parks
and I was like well well that is a good
idea so Elijah goes to school he does
his presentation he comes back home and
I can see something positive happened I
said well what happened son
he said well later on in that day the
teacher pulled me aside and she
apologized to me for giving that
misinformation and then something else
miraculous happened the next day she
actually taught a new lesson on Rosa
Parks filling in the gaps that she had
left and correcting the mistakes that
she made and I was so so proud of my son
but then I thought about it and I got
angry and I got real angry why why would
I get angry because my nine-year-old son
had to educate his teacher about his
history had to educate his teacher about
his own humanity he's nine years old he
should be thinking about basketball or
soccer or write the latest movie he
should not be thinking about having to
take the responsibility of educating his
teacher his his his students write about
himself about his history that was the
burden that I carry it was a bearing
that my parents carried and generations
before them carrying and now I was
seeing my son take on that burden too
you see that's why Rosa Parks wrote her
autobiography because during her
lifetime if you can imagine you do this
you you do this amazing thing you're
alive and you're talking about this your
civil rights activism and a story
emerges in which somebody is telling the
world that you were old and you had
tired feet and you just were an
accidental activist not that you had
been an activist by then for 20 years
not that the boycott had been planned
for months not that you were not even
the first or the second or even the
third woman to be arrested
for doing that right you become an
accidental activist even in our own
lifetime so she wrote that autobiography
to correct the record because what she
wanted to remind people of was that this
is what it was like in the 1950s trying
to be black in America and fight for
your rights during the year a little
over a year that the boycott lasted
there were over four Church bombings
Martin Luther King's house was bombed
twice
other civil rights leaders houses were
bombed in Birmingham Rosa Parks husband
slept at night with a shotgun because
they would get constant death threats in
fact Rosa Parks mother lived with them
and sometimes she would stay on the
phone for hours so that somebody would
so that nobody would call in with death
threats because it was constant and
persistent in fact there was so much
tension there was so much pressure there
was so much terrorism that Rosa Parks
and her husband they lost their jobs and
they became unemployable and eventually
had to leave and move out of the south
this is a civil rights reality that Rosa
Parks wanted to make sure that people
understood so you say well well David
what does that have to do with me I'm a
well-meaning person I didn't know in
slaves you know I'm not trying to
whitewash history I'm a good guy I'm a
good person let me tell you what it has
to do with you and I'll tell it to you
by telling you a story about a professor
of mine white professor when I was in
graduate school who was brilliant
brilliant individual we'll call him Fred
and Fred was writing this history of the
civil rights movement but he was writing
specifically about a moment that
happened to him in North Carolina when
this white man shot this black man in
cold blood in a wide open space and was
never convicted and so it was this great
book and he called to
together a couple of his professor
friends and he called me to have to read
a draft of it before final submission
and I was flattered that he called me I
was only a graduate student then and I
was kind of feeling you know feeling
myself a little bit okay yeah I'm
sitting around amongst intellectuals and
I read the draft of the book and there's
a moment in the book that struck me as
being deeply problematic and so I said
Fred as we were sitting around talking
about this draft I said Fred I've got a
real problem with this moment that you
talk about you're made in your book and
he said I could see Fred get a little
you know got a little tight as we say
and he said what do you mean that was
that's a great story I I that was a big
you know it happened just like I said I
said can I give you another scenario now
what's the story it was 1968 Martin
Luther King had just been assassinated
his maid domestic we'll call her
Maybelle was in the kitchen little Fred
is 8 years old little Fred comes into
the kitchen and Maybelle who he's all
he's only seen as smiling and helpful
and happy is bent over the sink and
she's crying and she's sobbing
inconsolably and little Fred comes over
to her and says Maybelle what is wrong
maybe I'll turns and she says they
killed him they killed our leader they
killed Martin Luther King he's dead they
are monsters and little Fred says it'll
be okay Maybelle it'll be okay it'll be
okay
and she looked at him she's no it's not
gonna be okay did you did you not hear
what I just said they killed Martin
Luther King and Fred son of a preacher
it looks up at Maybelle and he says but
Maybelle didn't Jesus died on the cross
for our sins wasn't that a good outcome
Mae
be this will be a good outcome maybe the
death of Martin Luther King will lead to
a good outcome and as Fred tells the
story he says that maybe I'll put her
hand over her mouth she reached down and
she gave little Fred hug and then she
reached into the icebox
and took out a couple Pepsi's gave him
some Pepsi's and sent him on his way to
play with the siblings and he said this
was proof that even in the most
harrowing times of race struggle that
two people could come together across
racial lines and find human commonality
along the lines of love and affection
and I said Fred that is some BS Fred was
he said Fred was like what but I don't
understand David I I'm really odd that
that's that's the story I said friend I
ask you a question I said you were in
North Carolina 1968 if maybe I would
have went to her community you were
eight years old what do you think the
eight year old african-american children
were calling her do you think they were
calling her by her first name
no they called her miss Maybelle or they
called her miss Johnson or they called
her Auntie Johnson they would have never
dare call her by her first name because
that would have been the height of
disrespect and yet you were calling her
by her first name every single day that
she worked and you never thought about
it
I said let me ask you another question
was Maybelle Mary did she have children
but what church did she go to what was
her favorite dessert tread could not
answer any of those questions I said
Fred this story is not about Maybelle
the story's about you I said this story
made you feel good but this story is not
about Maybelle the reality is what
probably happened was Maybelle was
crying which was not something she
customarily did so she was letting her
guard down and you came into the kitchen
and you caught her at a weak moment
where she was letting her guard down and
see because you thought of yourself it's
just like one of her children you didn't
recognize that you were in fact the
child of her employer and she found
herself yelling at you and then she
caught herself realizing that if I'm
yelling at him and he goes back and he
tells his dad or he tells mom I could
lose my job
and so she tempered herself and she
ended up even though she needed
consoling she ended up consoling you and
sending you on your way
perhaps so she could finish mourning in
peace and Fred was stunned and he
realized that he had actually misread
that moment and see this is what they
did to Rosa Parks because there's a lot
easier to digest
an old grandmother with tired feet who
doesn't stand up because she wants to
fight for any quality but because her
feet and her bat are tired and she's
worked all day she grandmother's old
grandmothers are not scary but young
radical black women who don't take any
stuff from anybody are very scary who
stand up to power and are willing to die
for that those are not the kind of
people that make us comfortable
so you say what do you want me to do
David I don't know what to do well what
I would say to you is there was a time
in which if you were Jewish you were not
white if you were Italian you were not
white if you were Irish you were not
white in this country it took a while
before the Irish Jews and the Italians
became white right there was a time in
which you were other when you were the
people on the outside Toni Morrison said
if in order for you to be tall I have to
be on my knees you have a serious
problem she says white America has a
serious serious problem to be honest I
don't know if race relations will
improve in America but I know that if
they will improve we have to take these
challenges on head-on the future of my
children depend on it the future of my
children's children depends on it and
whether you know it or not the future of
your children and your children's
children depends on it too thank you
[Applause]